la séance est ouverte
le contredit intégral de la séance du
mercredi 26 octobre a été publié sur le
site internet du Sénat nous n'avons pas
reçu l'observation il y en a t-il en
séance
je n'en vois point le procès-verbal est
donc adopté sous les réserves d'usage
madame la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues leur religion appelle les
questions d'actualité au Gouvernement je
vous rappelle que la séance est
retransmise sur Public Sénat en direct
et sur notre site internet chacun sera
attentif à respecter au cours de nos
échanges le respect qu'il s'agisse du
respect des uns et des autres ou celui
du temps de parole ceci fait partie des
principes du Sénat et je donne
immédiatement la parole au président
Claude Malhuret pour le groupe Les
Indépendants République et territoire
madame la Première ministre une fois de
plus les agriculteurs ont subi les
violences les intrusions les saccages
les destructions les harcèlements de
bandes de casseurs de Black Blocs et de
fichiers
soutenu par les idéologues d'une
écologie de la décroissance et par des
parlementaires qui se déshonorent en
participant à des manifestations
interdites dont ils connaissent à
l'avance les débordements
61 gendarmes blessés 61 gendarmes
blessés certains par des boules de
pétanque et des cocktails Molotov des
conduites d'eau détruites des champs
ravagés rien de nouveau c'est la
cinquième bassine attaquée en deux ans
celle de sainte Soline avait donné lieu
à un travail de concertation exemplaire
toutes les parties prenantes y compris
France Nature Environnement ont validé
le projet c'est celui d'une coopérative
c'est de l'économie sociale et solidaire
mais il s'en fiche totalement au moment
où Poutine couple gaz on s'aperçoit que
par leur faute on a plus assez d'énergie
nucléaire et que les Allemands n'ont
plus du tout au moment où il bloque les
bateaux qui partent du crâne les mêmes
veulent mettre à genoux notre
agriculture ils ont détruit en mer
dernier 1500 tonnes d'un train de blé
pour dire aux paysans qu'il faut
produire moins alors que l'Afrique
attend le blé français
combien de temps va durer le délire
anti-système d'une minorité de
contestataires gavés qui achète leur
salade en sachet dans les supermarchés
sans même comprendre qu'il faut de l'eau
pour la produire depuis des années
ce vandalisme se déroule dans
l'indifférence sur les 35 destructions
des installations de recherche végétales
28 plaintes ont été déposées 6 procès
ont été engagés une seule condamnation
en 2020 à Perpignan des juges ont même
reconnu l'état de nécessité pour relaxer
les casseurs madame la Première ministre
nous agricultures nos agriculteurs nous
éleveurs nos chercheurs n'en peuvent
plus l'immense majorité des Français les
soutiens mais on ne parle que de ceux
qui espèrent je les chefs de soupe et
qui bloquent les autoroutes ils ont
l'impression que personne ne les défend
pouvez-vous les rassurer et leur dire
que la fin de l'impunité est une
priorité pour le gouvernement
quand vous répondre la parole est comme
la première Mini
merci monsieur le président
comme vous comme beaucoup de Français
j'ai été choqué par les violences
auxquelles nous avons assisté le
week-end dernier à Sainte-Soline dans
les Deux-Sèvres et je veux avant toute
chose rendre hommage à nous forces de
l'ordre chaque jour policier et
gendarmes nous protègent ils préserve
l'ordre républicain aucune violence
contre n'est acceptable et le
gouvernement sera toujours à leur côté
alors Mesdames et Messieurs de quoi
parle-t-on à Sainte Soline un projet de
bassine porté et attendu par les
agriculteurs du territoire a fait
l'objet de concertation longue et
approfondie grâce à ces discussions le
projet a été fortement modifié et je
peux en témoigner en tant qu’ancienne
préfète de la région Poitou-Charente ce
projet s'inscrit dans le cadre du projet
de territoire pour la gestion de l'eau
qui a été approuvée en 2019 à la quasi
unanimité des collectivités bien sûr
mais aussi des associations de
protection de l'environnement ce projet
va permettre de réduire les prélèvements
dans les milieux naturels c'est un
projet responsable qui lit la
réalisation des réserves à des
engagements environnementaux pris par
les agriculteurs et c'est un projet qui
est également nécessaire pour aider ces
agriculteurs à faire face à la
sécheresse et pour mieux réguler l'usage
de l'eau je le dis clairement c'est un
bon projet il a passé toutes les étapes
des processus d'autorisation dans le
respect des règles de l'État de droit il
a pu faire l'objet de recours par les
opposants les opposants qui ont perdu
devant la justice malgré un projet
écologiquement vertueux comme le montre
les études du bureau des recherches
géologiques et minières malgré un projet
concerté et attendu par les agriculteurs
malgré les arrêtés d’interdiction de
manifester pris par la préfecture et
confirmée par la justice des
manifestations se sont tenues sur ce
site le week-end dernier
si la majorité des manifestants étaient
Pacifique plusieurs centaines
d'individus violents ont pris à partie
des gendarmes qui protégeaient le site
le bilan de leur action est lourd tire
de mortier jet de cocktails de
gendarmerie détruit et une soixantaine
de militaires blessés ce sont des scènes
inacceptables et profondément choquantes
malgré la grande violence de l'agression
les gendarmes ont tenu et sous
l'autorité du ministre de l'intérieur
ils ont maintenu l'ordre républicain et
je veux à nouveau les remercier et leur
rendre hommage et exprimer également
toute la solidarité et la solidarité du
gouvernement avec tous les gendarmes
blessés donc je le dis clairement
l'opposition à un projet ne justifie
jamais la violence la justice est saisie
et je peux vous assurer monsieur le
Président il n'y aura aucune impunité
pour ces auteurs de violence je vous
remercie
vous avez passé le temps
la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue Philippe mouiller pour le
groupe les républicains
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre madame monsieur des ministres
mes chers collègues je reviens entendu
sur le sujet de ce week-end à
Sainte-Souline où nous avons vécu un
weekend terrible dans les deux selles
dans mon département et je tiens
associer mon collègue giga Favreau ici
présent comme vous l'avez évoqué durant
deux jours cette commune de 350
habitants a vu déferler près de 4000
personnes participant à une
manifestation interdite par la
préfecture contestant la réalisation
d'une réserve de substitution
malheureusement comme cela a été
prévisible et ressenti environ 400
extrémistes violents étaient associés à
cette manifestation manifestation Cochin
également par leur présence par des élus
de la République qui appelle aujourd'hui
elle est désobéissance civique nous
avons vécu des scènes de violence inouïe
et comme vous l'avez fait madame le
Premier ministre je tiens également à
celluler l'engagement des forces de
l'ordre à apporter tout mon soutien aux
personnes blessés et à féliciter la
préfète des Deux-Sèvres
ce projet de réserve contesté par les
manifestants comme vous l'avez dit était
finalement validé par l'ensemble des
acteurs l'État le monde à l'école les
associations environnementales les élus
locaux ce projet est toujours dit
financer et légalement autorisé malgré
cela cette manifestation était
orchestrée au nom de l'écologie mais ce
n'est qu'un prétexte politique voulant
institut un système de violence et
d'anarchie depuis 24 heures aujourd'hui
s'insuline a retrouvé un peu de calme
mais elle risque est évoqué par les
médias il n'y a pas de Z mais les
agriculteurs et les habitants qui ont
été harcelés et qui méritent tout notre
soutien aspira de la tranquillité
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur
puisque ces questions étaient dédiées
face à ce type d'événements inquiétant
pour notre société quelle réponse
judiciaire qui réponses politiques
comment faire pour que demain à
Sainte-Souline comme partout en France
ou un projet d'aménagement et
démocratiquement autorisé nous puissions
le réaliser sereinement
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de l'Intérieur monsieur Gérald
Darmanin
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur comme vient de le dire madame
la Première ministre je veux moi aussi
comme vous l'avez fait comme la famille
remercier les 1700 gendarmes qui étaient
mobilisés donc plus de 60 vous l'avez vu
on était blessés dans quelques
intrigravement des mâchoires fracassées
des gens qui sont encore à l'hôpital au
moment où nous parlons il ne s'agit pas
de petits faits de délinquance qui se
sont déroulés dans votre département
mais les attaques graves contre les
responsables de l'ordre public alors
même que cette manifestation était
interdite cette interdiction validée par
la justice je veux moi aussi remercier
Madame la préfète de ce département qui
a été courageuse présente qui a
d'ailleurs je crois communiqué à bon
escient sans provocation mes proches des
agriculteurs et je veux ici dire aussi
que c'était l'outil travail des
agriculteurs qu'on a voulu casser et
tiendront toujours avoir le gouvernement
en associant le ministre de
l'Agriculture et le ministre la
transition écologique évidemment à leurs
côtés ces manifestations je mets des
guillemets extrêmement violentes ce
n'est pas le premier jour que le
gouvernement les connaît le gouvernement
avant nous les ont eu à les gérer je
pense notamment à Bernard Cazeneuve et
je veux rappeler que si aujourd'hui nous
pouvons afficher s un certain nombre de
personnes ultra violentes ultra
contestataires ou de l'ultra gauche
évoquant effectivement le fait que les
services de renseignement suivent ces
personnes c'est bien parce que un
gouvernement précédent celui du
président Hollande avait considéré que
l'ultra violence de l'ultra gauche était
une menace pour la nation pour l'ordre
républicain et donc à la fois les moyens
de renseignement qui nous ont permis de
mettre les 1700 gendarmes empêchant
ainsi la ZAD d'exister en constatant
monsieur le sénateur qu'il n'y a plus
que quelques dizaines de personnes
aujourd'hui plus personne n'en parle
mais il n'y a plus que quelques dizaines
de personnes près du site que les engins
de chantier vont reprendre leur chemin
pour construire cette bassine je veux
ici dire que nous suivrons
particulièrement cette difficulté
nouvelle qui est l'ordre public nouvelle
formule si j'ose dire des manifestations
spontanées violentes parfois extrêmement
radicalisées et je vous remercie d'avoir
voté la loi de programmation du
ministère de l'intérieur parce que vous
avez pris en génération cette menace et
vous avez donné les moyens mystères de
l'Intérieur d'y répondre
quelques secondes
monsieur le ministre nous avons besoin
de l'État dans cette opération nous ne
voulons pas revivre
Notre-Dame-des-Landes donc nous
souhaitons à moi meublée de chacun merci
la parole est à notre collègue Evelyne
Perrot pour le groupe de l'Union
centrices vous avez la parole monsieur
le Président Mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à Monsieur Becht
ministre du Commerce extérieur
aujourd'hui même en fin de matinée la
Russie a annoncé reprendre sa
participation à l'accord sur les
exportations de céréales ukrainiennes
après avoir reçu des garanties écrites
de la part de l'Ukraine sur le retrait
militaire du couloir de transport nous
ne pouvons que saluer cet excellente
nouvelle le monde entier retient son
souffle car avec la suspension de
l'accord sur les exportations de
céréales ukrainiennes nous ne sommes
peut-être pas passé loin d'une
catastrophe économique et humanitaire
cet accord est aujourd'hui vital pour la
sécurité alimentaire mondiale on ose
imaginer ce qu'il se serait passé si la
suspension avait duré
revanche un navire chargé de 40 tonnes
de céréales aurait dû partir pour
l'Éthiopie il est resté à quai lundi un
autre bateau à fouetté par le Programme
alimentaire mondial chargé de 30 000
tonnes de céréales destinées à Djibouti
est aussi resté bloqué cet épisode
montre que la Russie fait peser une épée
de Damoclès au-dessus de la sécurité
alimentaire mondiale une suspension
durable engendrerait une famille en
Afrique et une nouvelle flambée des prix
alimentaire monsieur le ministre se
prépare-t-on à une telle éventualité sur
le plan intérieur comment éviter qu'une
envolée des cours mondiaux de céréales
n'atteignent l'élevage hexagonale qui
dépend essentiellement du maïs et des
oléagineux Ukrainiens la présidente de
la FNSA est nsea nous a récemment
exprimé ses craintes à ce sujet et sur
le plan international pourrait-on en cas
de crise débloquée avec nos partenaires
européens et américains une aide
alimentaire exceptionnelle
pour vous répondre la parole est
communiste délégué en charge du commerce
extérieur Monsieur Olivier belge
merci monsieur le Président Madame et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Perrault d'abord je voudrais
excuser la ministre de l'Europe et des
Affaires étrangères Madame Catherine
Colonna d'autre part vous l'avez dit
madame la sénatrice la Russie a annoncé
aujourd'hui reprendre sa participation à
l'accord sur les exportations de
céréales ukrainiennes nous la prenons
homo en effet en suspendant aux
autofondances à participation en fin de
semaine dernière la Russie avait
poursuivi dans son cynisme dramatique
par un chantage alimentaire et en
choisissant délibérément de se servir de
la fin comme d'un moyen de pression et
d'une arme de guerre soyons clairs
l'initiative sur les exportations de
céréales en mer Noire portée par le
Secrétaire général des Nations Unies est
un succès 9 millions de tonnes de
céréales et d'autres produits
alimentaires ont exportés depuis le 22
juillet dernier par la voie maritime
l'ONU pour l'alimentation et
l'agriculture a confirmé que les prix du
blé avaient baissé sous l'effet de la
reprise des exp et c'est le meilleur
moyen pour maîtriser le prix sur les
marchés y compris notre propre sécurité
alimentaire dans sa guerre absurde et
dramatique la Russie est plus isolée que
jamais la dernière résolution portée par
l'Assemblée générale des Nations Unies
en soutien à l'Ukraine soutenu par 143
États en ates les conséquences de la
guerre inquiète et d'ailleurs pas
simplement chez nous sur tous les
continents tous les membres du Conseil
de sécurité y compris la Chine avait
vivement regretté d'ailleurs lundi la
décision du Kremlin de suspendre
l'accord sur les céréales je rappelle
que la France est à l'initiative pour
endiguer la crise alimentaire nous
continuerons donc à nous mobiliser avec
nos partenaires européens pour la mise
en oeuvre des voies de solidarité qui
ont permis l'exportation de près de 13
millions de tonnes de céréales et
d'autres produits alimentaires nous
soutenons également la création
prochaine dans la mécanisme d'urgence
d'achat groupé d'engrais pour l'Afrique
et la cheminement par le Programme
alimentaire mondial des céréales vers en
Afrique et le gouvernement est
évidemment à la manœuvre pour faire en
sorte que les prix restent contrôlés et
que les approvisionnements soient là y
compris sur nos marchés nationaux je
vous remercie madame Perrot quelques
secondes monsieur le ministre
aujourd'hui nous ne pouvons que nous
réjouir que le blocus est CC mais nous
avons tous en tête les images atroces de
la famille en de la famille en Éthiopie
et vraiment plus jamais ça
merci la parole comme notre collègue
Fabien gay pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologiste
avaient la parole merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues partout en France les réseaux
de transports en commun se dégradent et
c'est la galère quotidienne pour les
usagers dans toutes les régions les
autorités organisatrices sont confrontés
aux mêmes difficultés avec l'ouverture à
la concurrence les recrutements sont de
plus en plus difficiles et les
démissions sont légion le service se
dégrade et les TER sont pleins en
Île-de-France les rames de métro tram et
RER sont bondés le pire c'est le réseau
de bus qui en grande souffrance avec des
bus annulés sans raison et sans solution
de report quelques exemples franciliens
80 minutes d'attente pour le bus 545 en
Noisy-le-Sec ou encore 61 minutes pour
le bus 322 à Montreuil se rendre à
l'école au travail
à tout type d'obligation est devenu un
parcours du combattant le pire c'est
qu'en plus d'un service dégradé les
régions qui voient leur budget de plus
en plus contraints et qui refusent
d'augmenter le versement de transport
des entreprises envisage d'augmenter le
prix des abonnements pour les usagers en
Île-de-France le Pass Navigo pourrait
passer de 75 à 100 euros par mois c'est
un supportable pour les millions
d'usagers alors Monsieur le Ministre ma
question est simple quels moyens
supplémentaire sont prévus pour rétablir
des transports en commun fonctionnels
partout dans le pays
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre délégué chargé les transports
monsieur Clément bonne
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Fabien gay je vous rejoins sur
le fait que en Île-de-France en
particulier la situation les transports
publics n'est pas à la hauteur de la
première métropole d'Europe aujourd'hui
beaucoup ne concitoyens vivent des
galères ici à Paris et par tout en
Île-de-France cela s'est renforcé
disons-le clairement par des pénuries de
conducteurs je crois très sincèrement
que si nous voulons être efficace nous
vous partagez le détail des constats
cela n'a pas grand chose à voir avec
l'ouverture à la concurrence qui
d'ailleurs effective qu'en très petite
partie et les secteurs qui sont ouverts
à la concurrence connaissent exactement
les mêmes difficultés que les secteurs
qui ne sont pas ouverts à la concurrence
maintenant pour répondre à cette
difficulté il faut je crois deux choses
essentiellement la responsabilité et la
coopération la responsabilité c'est de
dire qui fait quoi nous l'avons besoin
de rappeler que c'est la région
Île-de-France
Île-de-France mobilité qui est en charge
de l'offre le transport qui doit la
définir qui doit l'améliorer qui doit
aussi fixer les prix il n'appartient pas
au gouvernement vous pouvez le déplorer
vous pouvez vous en satisfaire de fixer
le prix en l'occurrence du Pass Navigo
ni le prix du ticket quotidien pour les
transports publics franciliens la
coopération aussi la coopération aussi
car évidemment nous devons résoudre
cette question ensemble je rappelle que
pendant la crise de la covid en
particulier l'État a fait pour
l'Île-de-France cela a été légitime mais
cela mérite d'être rappelé aussi un
effort qui n'a fait qui n'a été fait
dans aucune autre région de plus de 1,3
milliards d'euros dont 150 millions
d'euros de subventions et le reste en
avance remboursable nous devons
aujourd'hui améliorer les choses par
exemple chez nos grands opérateurs à la
RATP à la SNCF c'est pour ça je le
soutiens que la RATP notamment met en
place des primes supplémentaires que la
région les soutient d'ailleurs enfin et
qu'un plan de recrutement de 1500
chauffeurs a été déployé pour résoudre
une partie de ces difficultés c'est pour
ça que nous devons prolonger aussi nos
investissements et continuer à préparer
l'avenir nous aurons à négocier dans les
prochaines semaines un nouveau contrat
de plan est à région là aussi c'est
inédit l'état mis 40% dans le précédent
contrat de planétari région avec
l'Île-de-France nous serons aussi au
rendez-vous pour le prochain contrat de
plan qui sera en discussion nous devons
aussi continuer d'investir dans la
préparation de l'avenir c'est pour ça je
le rappelle puisque ce bud sera en
discussion devant le Sénat très
prochainement qu'il y a un milliard
d'euros d'investissements pour
l'amélioration et transports publics au
titre du développement de nouvelles
lignes à travers la Société du Grand
Paris donc nous devons trouver une
solution je suis ouvert à d'autres
options ensemble en responsabilité dire
qui fait quoi et en coopération aussi
monsieur
le ministre c'est tout un modèle
économique qu'il faut revoir ce n'est
pas aux usages à payer l'ouverture à la
concurrence vous voulez recruter des
chauffeurs de bus alors augmenter les
salaires augmenter le versement
transport des entreprises et faites
voter dans le prochain budget une aide
supplémentaire il manque 700 millions à
l'Île-de-France pour que les autorités
organisatrices puissent investir dans
les transports en commun c'est une
urgence sociale écologique pour éviter
que des millions d'usagers reprennent
leur voiture individuelle enfin le 10
novembre prochain il y aura une journée
d'action des salariés de la RATP la SNCF
pour exiger plus de moyens nous serons à
leur côté et nous continuerons porter
ses propositions et à dire que il ne
faut pas augmenter le prix des
abonnements pour les usagers
la parole est à notre collègue Martin
lévrier pour le gros mot le groupe du
Rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendants
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à Olivier du soft
ministre du Travail du plein emploi et
de l'insertion
aide à domicile aide-soignant agent
d'entretien serveur maçon plombier
chauffagiste ouvrit les travaux publics
employés de libre-services tous ces
métiers ont un point commun celui d'être
des métiers sous tension phénomène
accentués par une reprise économique
post covid plus rapide et plus forte on
ne compte plus les secteurs qui font
actuellement face à ces pénuries de main
d'oeuvre chacun d'entre nous le constate
au quotidien dans son territoire nous
sommes nombreux à être saisis par des
employeurs qui peinent à recruter et qui
sont en manque de solutions concrètes
donc première mesure ont été mises en
oeuvre par le gouvernement bonus malus
alternance apprentissage pour densité
que trois cependant au regard de la
complexité de certaines réalités locales
cela ne suffit pas pour résoudre ces
difficultés de recrutement une autre
piste pourrait être envisagée celle du
recours à la main d'oeuvre étrangère
déjà présente sur le territoire national
il importe de rappeler que le taux de
chômage de ce public avoisine les 15%
alors qu'un grand nombre de demandes
qu'une chose travailler et avoir une
situation stable régulière et sécurisée
en un mot s'intégrer par le travail
monsieur le ministre dans le cadre de la
réflexion sur le futur projet de loi
asile et immigration que prévoyez-vous
pour encourager cette insertion par le
travail et enfin pour répondre à la
problématique des métiers sous tension
vous avez évoqué dans une interview
donnée avec monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur et de l'outre-mer Gérald
Darmanin
une deuxième idée celle de créer un
titre de séjour métier en tension
pourriez-vous nous en préciser les
comptes les contours je vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre du Travail
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur lévrier vous l'avez dit avec
Gérald Darmanin nous avons rendu public
les premières orientations les premières
pistes de travail autour desquels nous
aurons l'occasion de débattre avec vous
à l'occasion d'un débat parlementaire
avant la fin de l'année puis dans le
cadre de l'examen d'un futur texte de
loi autour de l'immigration nos
objectifs sont très simples en réalité
c'était la fois mieux faire respecter
les règles faire en sorte que les
décisions de justice les décisions
administratives soient mieux appliquées
et ça nécessite aussi de la fermeté des
moyens dans leur application mais c'est
aussi faire en sorte que les étrangers
présents en France soient mieux intégrés
nous sommes convaincus que le travail et
le premier outil d'intégration des
étrangers qui vivent sur notre sol ça a
longtemps été le cas et depuis le
chômage de masse ce lien entre le
travail l'immigration l'intégration
s'est distendue nous devons remettre ce
chantier en ordre et faire en sorte que
le travail redevienne une valeur
d'intégration notre système aujourd'hui
ne le permet pas nous avons des trappes
une activité avec un certain nombre de
demandeurs d'asile dont nous savons
pertinemment ils viennent de pays
suffisamment dangereux pour que l'asile
soit accordé qu'ils doivent attendre
très longtemps avant d'avoir le droit de
travailler nous avons des immigrés qui
bénéficient d'un titre de séjour pour
raison professionnelle qui doivent
solliciter une autorisation
administrative pour chaque contrat de
travail il faut aussi leur simplifier la
vie et puis nous le savons nous avons
aussi des travailleurs en situation
irrégulière mais qui travaillent parfois
depuis longtemps et dans des métiers en
tension le métier de la restauration le
métier parfois du bâtiment nous avons
d'ores et déjà procédé un certain nombre
de régularisations je pense à
l'application de la circulaire prise par
Manuel Valls qui concerne 7000
admissions exceptionnelles au séjour
mais c'est régularisation nécessite un
engagement un accompagnement de
l'employeur nous voulons que ces
travailleurs en situation irrégulière
mais dont nous avons tant besoin
puissent eux-mêmes solliciter leur
régularisation
il ne s'agit pas d'une régularisation
massive c'est du cas par cas c'est de
l'étude de dossier il faudra pouvoir
prouver d'une ancienneté sur le
territoire de l'exercice d'un métier
apparaissant sur la liste des métiers en
tension mais ça répondra à la fois aux
besoins de l'économie et ça répondra
encore plus profondément à un besoin une
volonté de construire un projet
personnel un projet familial et un site
facilité l'intégration de ces hommes et
de ces femmes qui travaillent sur notre
sol et qui vivent avec nous
[Applaudissements]
notre collègue Christian Redon sarrazi
pour le groupe socialiste écologiste
hérétique
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre en raison des crises
successives un nombre croissant de nos
concitoyens se trouvent en situation de
grande précarité et ils sont de plus en
plus nombreux à devoir recourir à l'aide
alimentaire pour se nourrir au quotidien
dans mon département les bénéficiaires
de la Banque alimentaire ont augmenté de
5 % en venant ça le représente
aujourd'hui 42000 personnes soit plus de
10% de la population de la Haute-Vienne
l'aide alimentaire a su ce
professionnaliser pour répondre à ces
nouvelles demandes mais elle fait face à
une grave pénurie de produits en raison
d'un scandaleux gaspillage les
organisations constatent avec amertume
que la loi Garraud n'est pas respectée
de nombreux magasins et entreprises du
secteur agroalimentaire persiste à jeter
d'importantes quantités de produits qui
pourraient pourtant résoudre les
problèmes d'approvisionnement on compte
d'ailleurs à ce jour une baisse de 6% de
la ramasse de ses produits pourquoi pour
essentiellement une question de profit
plutôt que de donner la totalité de
leurs excédents aux associations les
grands groupes préfèrent revendre leur
surproduction à des déstockeurs chez qui
se retrouvent le gaspillage alimentaires
car ils peinent à revendre tous les
produits récupérés une solution multiple
bénéfices consisterait à obtenir des
produits en circuit court auprès des
agriculteurs et des producteurs locaux
disposant d'excédents le problème est
qu'il ne bénéficie actuellement d'aucune
mesure de défiscalisation pour les dons
qu'il pourrait effectuer madame la
ministre que comptez-vous faire pour
faire appliquer correctement la loi
garrot que proposez-vous pour soutenir
la chalocale et plus largement l'aide
alimentaire
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
secrétaire d'été en charge de l'économie
sociale et solidaire madame Schiappa
n'avait la parole
merci monsieur le président madame la
Première ministre monsieur le sénateur
Christian Redon sarrazi je vous remercie
d'abord pour votre question relative à
la question du gaspillage alimentaire et
vous avez raison de rappeler la loi
portée par Guillaume Garraud qui a
notamment permis d'interdire de rendre
un propre les denrées alimentaires et
d'obliger les acteurs à porter une
convention de dons avec une association
habilité chargée de la vie associative
je veux bien sûr commencer par rendre
hommage à toutes ces associations et à
ses acteurs de l'économie sociale et
solidaire qui s'engagent très
concrètement sur le sujet du gaspillage
alimentaire mais je veux rappeler
également que lors du précédent
quinquennat nous avons continué à œuvrer
pour renforcer cette lutte notamment
avec les lois et Gallim mais aussi avec
la loi à Jacques dans ce cadre nous nous
sommes fixés l'objectif de réduction de
50% du gaspillage alimentaire d'ici
l'année 2030 et pour cela nous
impliquons l'ensemble des acteurs de la
chaîne en renforçant les exigences en
matière de suivi de contrôle de qualité
de dons d'obligation de dons d'ailleurs
via la restauration collective et je
vous annonce que nous lancerons
prochainement un label national
anti-gaspillage afin de clarifier et de
valoriser ces initiatives il se
rapporter par Marc fenault et Christophe
Béchu chargé de l'agriculture et de la
transition écologique merci pour eux
c'est donc une mesure de la loi Ajac que
nous pourrons mettre en œuvre parce que
comme vous le savez les Français sont
toujours plus sensibles à leur manière
de consommer l'entreprise de l'économie
sociale et solidaire Phénix dit par
exemple que 84% des Français privilégie
un supermarché
identifié par un label de ce type la
question du gaspillage alimentaire et de
l'accès à l'alimentation sont
fondamentale pour nous c'est d'ailleurs
pourquoi demain la première ministre
Elisabeth borne ira en déplacement dans
une banque alimentaire et nous aurons
l'honneur de l'accompagner avec le
ministre des Solidarités Jean-Christophe
combe pour être toujours au plus près
des acteurs de terrain je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
je me doutais de cette réponse qu'il en
est pas vraiment une
effectivement vous dites que vous avez
fait des choses pour le pour la
solidarité alimentaire mais ce que vous
oubliez de dire c'est qu'au gouvernement
avant le vôtre n'avait autant fait il
n'avait autant créer de précarité par
les choix politiques et budgétaires qui
ont été les siens dans ce contexte le
gap le gaspillage alimentaire et le
manque de solidarité sont intolérable
pour nos concitoyens lors des débats
budgétaires qui vont s'ouvrir au Sénat
notre groupe proposera des mesurer
immédiates et concrètes pour faire face
à l'aggravation de la crise à
l'inflation record que subit le pays
afin que la solidarité est notamment la
solidité la solidarité alimentaire soit
dignement assurée merci la parole est à
notre collègue
Eric gold pour le groupe du
Rassemblement démocratique et social
européen merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre 12 millions de
Français sont victimes de précarité
énergétique parce qu'ils vivent dans une
passoire thermique ou ne peuvent pas se
chauffer comme il le souhaiterait avec
la crise énergétique et l'hiver qui
arrive il est à craindre que ce chiffre
augmente de manière dramatique
le nécessaire rénovation massive des
logements doit donc plus que jamais être
une priorité le rythme des rénovations
et l'efficacité de ma prime rénov
doivent être renforcés car la France
compte encore plus de 5 millions de
passoires thermiques c'est aussi un
enjeu de transition écologique le
logement représente 43% de nos
consommations énergétiques et génèrent
23% des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre après la Défenseur des droits qui
a pointé de nombreux dysfonctionnements
dans le traitement des demandes de
subvention la Cour des comptes vient de
publier sa dernière évaluation citant de
trop nombreuses réformes ayant nuit à la
lisibilité du dispositif un suivi
approximatif de son efficacité un
pilotage inadéquate et la complexité des
structures d'accompagnement beaucoup de
territoires pourtant très engagés pour
apporter un soutien technique et
financier aux porteur de projets font
aussi remonter les obstacles à
l'aboutissement des dossiers
procédure longue et complexe instructeur
qui ne répondent pas de vie trop
spécifiques qui mettent en difficulté
nos artisans locaux sans compter les
dossiers complets qui attendent depuis
un an le versement de la prime
par ailleurs
outre des problèmes techniques
récurrents sur la plateforme la
dématérialisation totale de la procédure
exclut certains bénéficiaires potentiels
je rappelle que 14 millions de Français
souffrent d'électronisme problématique
que mon groupe connaît bien puisque nous
avons fait adopter par le Sénat une
proposition de loi sur ce sujet l'an
dernier
or les guichets rénovation et les
maisons France services n'ont ni le
temps ni les moyens d'accompagner dans
le détail chaque demandeur aussi
Monsieur le Ministre avec le coût de
l'énergie qui explose et qui impacte
fortement le pouvoir d'achat des ménages
comment améliorer le dispositif pour ne
laisser aucun bénéficiaire sur le bord
du chemin je vous remercie pour vous
répondre la parole est au ministre
délégué en charge du logement monsieur
Klein vous avez la parole
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur gold vous avez raison ma prime
rénov est un dispositif essentiel pour
notre transition écologique comme vous
le soulignez ce dispositif doit être
accessible au plus grand nombre et à
ceux qui en ont le plus besoin je tiens
à dire que ce dispositif est perfectible
bien évidemment et nous y travaillons
tous les jours d'arrache-pied avec
l'ensemble des membres du gouvernement
mais néanmoins c'est 1,5 millions de
chantiers qui ont eu vu le jour depuis
deux ans soit plus que l'objectif qui
nous avait été donné par le Président de
la République et par Madame la première
ministre puisque l'objectif était de 700
000 logements par an néanmoins il faut
aller plus loin au-delà de cette
massification il faut aller plus loin
dans la performance de ces chantiers et
dans la globalisation des moyens qui
sont donnés à chacun de porter ce projet
de rénovation thermique c'est pour ça
que l'accueil France rénov par un
conseiller France Renov et renforcé que
nous allons de mettre en place des
accompagnateurs rénov pour que chacun
puisse avoir toutes les informations
nécessaires et c'est aussi pour ça que
dans le PLF 2023 nous avons encore
augmenté le projet ma prime rénov à 2,6
milliards d'euros bien évidemment
c'est dispositifs touchent l'ensemble du
territoire 49% des chantiers sont dans
des chantiers en zone rurale et au
regard de la population de ces zones ça
démontre que ces quartiers sont ces
zones rurales sont particulièrement
touchées bien évidemment les passoires
thermiques sont aussi en zone dense et
nous travaillons aussi d'arrache-pied
sur la question de l'habitat collectif
et des copropriétés c'est le sens de ma
prime rénov copropriété sur lequel nous
travaillons aussi pour ouvrir le champ
permettre aux conseils syndicaux et aux
copropriétaires d'accéder à des
chantiers en toute connaissance de cause
je peux vous assurer que nous sommes
extrêmement mobilisés que nous lisons
comme vous l'ensemble des rapports qui
pointent des dysfonctionnements mais
comme on dit nos jetons pas le bébé avec
l'eau du bain il y a beaucoup d'effets
qui ont déjà extrêmement positifs sur ma
prime juste un exemple les 1,5 millions
c'est l'équivalent d'économie de des
consommations d'énergie de la ville de
Lyon que nous avons déjà économisé pour
le portefeuille et pour la planète merci
la parole de notre collègue Daniel
seulement pour le groupe écologie
solidarité territoire vous avez la
parole
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre revenons dans les Deux Sèvres
nous dénonçons le déni démocratique et
le court termisme la manière dont
s'implante les méga bassines est
révélateur d'une absence de gouvernance
partagée autour des orientations
agricoles d'un territoire pourtant
d'autres solutions paysannes et
innovantes d'irrigation existent adaptée
au changement climatiques elles sont
déjà pratiquées sur les fermes
d'agroécologie monsieur le ministre
quand allez-vous stopper ces projets non
pensés qui reviennent à poser une
rustine sur un schéma sans avenir à
quand une gestion de l'eau transparente
démocratique et profitable à toutes et à
tous votre gouvernement parle uniquement
de la violence et agite scandaleusement
le mot déco terrorisme une stratégie
d'écran de fumée pour ne pas parler du
fond
on va répondre la parole est au ministre
la transition écologique et de la
cohésion des territoires monsieur le
Président Madame la première ministre
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur seulement
oui vous avez raison la question de
l'eau mérite mieux que des postures
elles mérite en tout cas certainement
mieux que des cassages en règle comme ce
à quoi nous avons assisté pendant tout
le weekend
vous avez
vous avez soutenu à la primaire
écologiste Yannick Jadot en défendant
l'idée au moment où vous lui avez porté
son soutien qu'il y avait besoin
d'incarner une écologie politique qui
soit faite de respectabilité on a vu la
manière dont l'écologie politique est
respectable était accueillies par une
minorité de manifestants avec ses
inscriptions très poétiques sur les
portières de la voiture maintenant pour
aller sur le fond pour aller sur le fond
il s'agit de réserves de substitution
de substitution c'est à dire très
précisément que ce projet il est soumis
à des autorisations il vise à faire
baisser les prélèvements de 70% dans les
étiages vous invoquez la science les
études du BRGM du mois de juillet
démontre qu'on préserverait à la fois le
niveau des nappes pendant l'été et que
nous aurions un impact positif en
sécurisant les alimentations d'eau
potable et en faisant en sorte de
préserver la biodiversité
si vous allez du côté de la science vous
avez des arguments maintenant j'aimerais
qu'on s'arrête sur les slogans oui la
priorité c'est la préservation de l'eau
ce n'est donc de diminuer nos
prélèvements et nos usages c'est la
priorité elle est au coeur à la fois des
Assises du varen et de la démarche que
nous avons lancé avec Bérengère
Couillard à la fin du mois de septembre
à Marseille la caparment pour la grippe
business on a affaire à 300 agriculteurs
en coopérative qui pour la plupart sont
dans la polyculture élevage on a un
projet qui n'est pas celui du
gouvernement qui est celui par la région
socialiste par le Département
républicain par les élus ruraux de tout
bord et quand on parle d'acaparent s'il
vous plaît un agriculteur quand il fait
une réserve il a fait pas pour sa
consommation personnelle mais pour nous
nourrir à la fin on augmentera les
importations si on condamne les
adaptations de notre modèle agricole
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
monsieur le ministre il ne vous a pas
échappé que nous venons de vivre une
année dramatique avec la canicule et la
sécheresse avec des aléasis qui ne sont
pas prises en compte dans les études de
BRGM on se base sur des statistiques sur
les années les décennies passées c'est
pas ça qui va se produire demain votre
politique du bulldozer pour soutenir un
système obsolète ne pourra pas durer
longtemps comme ça
la parole est au président François Noël
buffet pour le groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'Intérieur et
des Outre-mer
nous venons de vivre un week-end
dramatique et pour cause la violence à
Sainte Soline a atteint des sommets dont
on peut craindre qu'elle puisse
éventuellement se renouveler ce que nous
ne souhaitons pas
des forces de l'ordre des gendarmes ont
été blessés nombreux
cela est inacceptable naturellement
d'ailleurs il faut saluer leur travail
ainsi que celui de la préfète qui a
piloté les opérations mais
cette montée de violence elle est venue
ailleurs sous d'autres formes on a
dégradé à un moment des œuvres d'art
on a également
bloquer la circulation manifestée créer
des tensions extrêmement fortes
y compris avec des risques de conflits
réels
dans deux ans la France organise des
jeux olympiques de 2024 dès l'année
prochaine la Coupe du monde de rugby
monsieur le ministre on nous a indiqué
que tout ce travail était en préparation
vous êtes venu vous exprimer
récemment devant la commission de la
culture ainsi que la commission des lois
au regard de ce que nous vivons en ce
moment et de cette montée de violence
inacceptable comment êtes-vous en train
de préparer cette opération avec quels
moyens et surtout à quel moment
déposerez-vous un texte devant le
Parlement pour que nous puissions
légiférer je le pense en tous les cas au
plus vite
on va répondre la parole de communiste
de l'Intérieur monsieur Gérald Darmanin
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
Président buffet comme vous je constate
et c'est vrai dans beaucoup de pays qui
nous entourent que les grands événements
ou les grandes expositions les grands
moments médiatiques sont aussi le moment
des contestations les plus violentes
symbolique mais vous l'avez dit
vous-même les plus violentes et que nous
nous préparer à cela au moment
d'accueillir des grands événements
sportifs la Coupe du monde de rugby en
septembre prochain et les Jeux
olympiques de Paris
vous avez bien voulu souligner que je
suis devenu je suis venu à votre demande
détaillée les moyens que va mettre le
ministère de l'Intérieur à la demande de
la première ministre et du président de
la République pour garantir la sécurité
en termes d'ordre public de lutte contre
le terrorisme mais évidemment lutte
contre la délinquance et j'ai eu
l'occasion de vous dire que les 45 000
policiers gendarmes qui seront mobilisés
chaque jour sont sans précédent dans
l'histoire d'autres pays pour prendre au
sérieux bien évidemment cette menace
vous évoquez quel texte nous allons
déposer je vais vous dire que vous
l'avez déjà en très grande partie étudié
monsieur le Président puisque la loi
d'orientation et de programmation du
ministère de l'Intérieur celle qui
recrée 11 unités supplémentaires de
force mobile qui renforce
considérablement les renseignements et
je pense que l'une des clés de notre
réussite si j'ose dire ce weekend était
le renseignement qui a bien fonctionné
qui nous a permis de proportionner la
réponse en nombre de gendarmes de
pouvoir mobiliser l'action de Madame la
préfète pour empêcher la ZAD de
s'installer et des travaux de la bassine
de continuer à être effectué ce
renseignement va être considérablement
renforcé vous le savez monsieur le
Président dans la loi qui est en ce
moment en train de discuter à semer
nationale il est par ailleurs des
dispositions qui peuvent concerner
directement les grands événements
sportifs il n'appartient pas à cette
première ministre de le faire que de
pouvoir voir comment nous pouvons
compléter ou améliorer avec la ministre
des Sports les moyens pour aider les
préfectures et les forces de l'ordre
d'intervenir le mieux possible il est
évident monsieur le Président que nous
sommes tous très rencontrer pour que la
fête du sport des collions de rugby ou
des Jeux Olympiques ne soient pas le
lieu de l'ultra violence d'où qu'elles
viennent en quelque sorte le sujet
monsieur le Président buffet
chez le président
600000 personnes sont attendues sur les
quais de Seine et plus dans Paris
naturellement pour cet événement avec
Laurent Laffont nous avons après les
événements du Stade de France fait une
quinzaine de propositions vous avez
indiqué vouloir les reprendre en compte
c'est parfait mais parmi ces
propositions il y avait la manière
d'associer les deux commissions et le
Parlement à ce travail préparatoire pour
s'assurer qu'effectivement il souhaite
une véritable réussite pour la France et
nous attendons évidemment vos
propositions de ce point de vue là merci
merci monsieur le président
la parole est à notre collègue
Usain Bourgi pour le robe socialiste
écologiste
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
Clément bonne ministre des Transports
monsieur le ministre le 15 décembre 2013
c'est dans la joie que la ligne à grande
vitesse
reliée le Languedoc-Roussillon à la
Catalogne la France à l'Espagne à raison
de quatre dessertes par jour entre Paris
et Barcelone en passant par Valence
Nîmes Montpellier et Perpignan ce sont
des chefs d'entreprise des scolaires des
étudiants des touristes qui ont voyagé
dans les deux sens nous venons
d'apprendre
qu'en raison de l'ouverture à la
concurrence et des accords commerciaux
entre la reine fait et la SNCF à compter
du 11 décembre prochain c'est 4 desserts
quotidiennes aller passer à deux nous
avons appris à la même occasion que la
ligne à grande vitesse entre Lyon et
Barcelone s'arrêter et la ligne à grande
vitesse entre Marseille et Madrid
s'arrêtait aussi monsieur le ministre à
l'instar de tous les élus de ma région
l'Occitanie mais des régions voisines
aussi à l'instar des chambres
consulaires des acteurs économiques à
l'instar de toutes celles et ceux qui
ont œuvré depuis tant d'années pour que
nous puissions relier le sud de la
France à l'Espagne nous en appelons à
votre autorité ainsi qu'à celle de votre
homologue espagnol afin que les
dirigeants des deux entreprises la SNCF
RNC reviennent à la raison dans
l'intérêt de nos territoires le
développement économique je vous
remercie
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre délégué en charge du transport
vous avez la parole monsieur Beaune
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur vous avez raison
sur l'importance stratégique de cette
lésion qui a été inauguré il y a un peu
moins d'une décennie et il avait été
indiqué à la suite de la crise covid
d'une effondre un effondrement des
trafics mais néanmoins de la nécessaire
préservation de cette ligne par la SNCF
d'une part et son partenaire espagnol la
reine fait l'autre part il y a quelques
mois qu'à la fin de l'année leur
partenariat s'arrêterait je lui
reviendrait cela n'est pas irréversible
mais aujourd'hui cela signifie qu'il
faut réorganiser cette se fait par étape
il y a une première étape qui commencera
le 11 décembre prochain et qui permettra
à la SNCF seul d'avoir d'ores et déjà
deux allers-retours entre Paris et
Barcelone ça n'est pas l'offre que vous
évoquez mais c'est une première étape et
ça n'est pas la fin de ce partenariat ou
de l'histoire de cette liaison c'est
très important d'ailleurs de préciser
aussi puisque vous avez rappelé
l'importance pour votre territoire en
particulier de cette liaison que ces
deux allers-retours passeront par le
département de l'Hérault en particulier
avec des arrêts à Montpellier à 7 à Agde
et nous continuerons encourager cette
coopération nouvelle coopération entre
la SNCF et le fait pour améliorer
l'offre je m'engage à mener ce travail
avec mon homologue espagnol sur ce sujet
j'ai échangé avec elle le 21 octobre
dernier je la rencontrerai à Madrid dans
le début d'année en liaison évidemment
avec les élus et les parlementaires
concernés en particulier sur les autres
liaisons je tiens à préciser aussi que
ce qui se mettent en place à défaut de
ce partenariat renouvelé c'est que la
reine fait va reprendre les liaisons
entre Lyon et Barcelone d'une part entre
Madrid et Marseille d'autre part et donc
il y aura bien une liaison qu'il a aussi
sera reconduite même si les fréquences
doivent être encore rediscutées je
précise aussi puisque cela est une autre
liaison importante entre la France et
l'Espagne même si vous l'avez pas évoqué
que il y a une un cadre qui s'arrête à
la fin de l'année aussi pour la liaison
entre Perpignan et Figueras et que je me
suis engagé avec mon homologue espagnol
a demandé à nos deux opérateurs de
trouver aussi une solution de continuité
pour cette liaison donc je suis prêt à
continuer de travailler avec vous pour
que nous améliorions les choses pour que
ce partenariat même s'il n'est pas
reconduit l'identique déboucher sur
d'autres types d'options qu'il n'y ait
pas une pénalisation de ces liaisons qui
sont importantes je rappelle aussi
puisque vous avez évoqué la question de
la concurrence que notre opérateur la
SNCF est présent sur le marché espagnol
je crois pour le bienfait de
l'entreprise et aussi pour le bienfait
le million d'utilisateurs sur la liaison
entre Madrid et Barcelone
le second
merci mais vous n'avez pas tout à fait
répondu à ma question m'avait répondu en
apportant des éléments sur une offre qui
sera dégradée et qui dit offre dégradé
ça veut dire impossibilité de faire
l'aller-retour dans la journée et ça
concerne en particulier les chefs
d'entreprise lorsque vous me dites que
dans quelques semaines ou dans quelques
mois la reine fait pourrait exploiter ou
reprendre certaines lignes rien n'est
acquis à ce jour et puisque vous avez
évoqué le covid monsieur le ministre je
voulais vous dire que partout en France
sur le territoire national et je vais
parler des liaisons entre Bordeaux et
Paris entre Brest et Paris rien n'est
satisfaisant parce que nous ne sommes
pas revenus à la situation antérieure au
covid aujourd'hui les trains
fonctionnent ils sont pleins remplis les
prix flambes avec parfois une
incestivation des voyageurs puisque
effectivement il y a des retards et je
vous demande vraiment de réfléchir la
stratégie de la France en matière de LGV
la parole est à madame la présidente
Catherine de roche pour le groupe les
républicains
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adressait à la ministre des Affaires
étrangères le 14 septembre dernier le
président Larcher recevait le docteur
Denis mucoege prix Nobel de la Paix 2018
ce médecin gynécologue obstétricien
opère chaque semaine dans son hôpital de
panzy des victimes de viol et de
mutilation perpétrée dans l'est de la
République démocratique du Congo ces
violences sont connues depuis plus de 20
ans en 2010 un rapport de l'ONU rapport
Mappy dénonçait ses crimes de guerre or
depuis rien ne bouge vraiment et le tout
sur fond d'enjeux économiques importants
dans cette zone qui est un gros
producteur de cobalt et de coltan donc
ma question est la suivante quelle a été
quelle est l'action de la France pour
porter la voix au niveau international
de ces populations martyrisées qui
mérite certes la reconnaissance mais
surtout condamnation des auteurs justice
et réparation
merci
[Applaudissements]
pour vous répondre
la parole est à Monsieur Olivier bèche
ministre délégué chargé du Commerce
mystérieux notre activité et les
Français de l'étranger merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs madame la Présidente de roche
en effet la recrudescence des violences
dans l'est de la République démocratique
du Congo est préoccupante en particulier
la reprise des combats entre le M23 et
les forces armées de la RDC depuis le 20
octobre après plus de trois mois
d'acalmie nous condamnons depuis
longtemps les activités de tous les
groupes armés les appelant à cessé le
combat à déposer les armes et à prendre
part au processus de désarmement de
démobilisation et de réintégration
il est nécessaire que toutes les parties
mettent en oeuvre rapidement leurs
engagements notamment ceux qui ont été
pris lors d'une réunion initiée le 21
septembre dernier par le Président de la
République à New York pour établir un
dialogue régional apaisé et contribue à
la stabilité dans l'Est de la RDC la
situation actuelle démontre l'importance
de la lutte contre l'impunité en RDC la
France joue un rôle moteur au sein du
Conseil de sécurité des sciences unies
pour ce que la Monusco continue à être
doté d'un mandat exigeant en la matière
et elle soutient également la mise en
oeuvre de mesures restrictives au niveau
des Nations Unies et de l'Union
européenne contre des personnalités
responsables de graves violations des
droits de l'homme enfin nous soutenons
depuis de très nombreuses années
l'action du docteur denim en faveur des
femmes victimes de violences sexuelles
notamment à travers l'appui à son
hôpital et à sa fondation abukavu dans
la droite ligne de l'engagement pris par
le Président de la République lors du
sommet du G7 présidé par la France en
2019 notre pays a également mobilisé
plus de 6 millions d'euros au profit du
fond mondial pour les survivantes de
violences sexuelles liées au conflit
qu'il a créé avec Nadia Mourad merci
donc
en effet le docteur denimeux compte
beaucoup sur la France et sur les autres
pays d'ailleurs et je voudrais dire ces
propos qu'il avait tenu lors de son prix
sakarov en 2014 chaque femme violée je
l'identifie à ma femme chaque mer violet
je l'identifie à ma mère chaque enfant
violet je l'identifie à mes enfants
quelle est cet être humain doué de
conscience qui se terrait quand on lui
amène un bébé de 6 mois dans le vagin
était détruit soit par le pénétration
brutale d'un adulte soit par des objets
contondants soit par des produits
chimiques comment me taire quand depuis
15 ans nous voyons ce que même un oeil
de chirurgien ne peut s'habituer à voir
c'était il lui a eu du temps la France
ne peut pas ne doit pas détourner le
regard et la France ne peut pas se taire
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue Michel
Canivet pour le groupe de l'Union sans
plus
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres chers collègues la France est
un grand pays maritime et nous
souhaitons qu'elle le demeure à
l'approche en fin de semaine des 4e
rencontre du transmence à Saint-Malo et
avant les assises de l'économie de la
mer la semaine prochaine à Lille je
souhaite interroger le gouvernement sur
les conditions de concurrence sur le
transport maritime dans le transmanche
et aussi il faut le dire en Méditerranée
effectivement les amateurs sont
affrontés à des conditions de
concurrence qui ne sont plus égales
puisque un certain nombre d'opérateurs
utilisent de la main d'oeuvre à bas coût
qui n'est pas européenne pour assurer
les liaisons et ceci n'est pas
acceptable parce que les conditions
salariales imposées ne sont pas
respectées parce que les temps de
travail ne sont pas respectés non plus
donc il importe effectivement que c'est
que ces conditions de concurrence
puissent être restaurées c'est pourquoi
je souhaite demander ce que le
gouvernement en train de faire pour
essayer de d'assainir la situation
pour vous répondre la parole est au
secrétaire d'État en charge de la mer
Monsieur Hervé Berville merci monsieur
le Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur canvez
merci de votre question qui permet et
qui est plus large que la question des
ferries du transmence qui est celle au
fond du modèle social pour notre
économie maritime et si la France doit
demeurer une puissance maritime
importante elle doit l'être dans le
cadre de ces valeurs de son identité
également du renforcement du modèle
social vous l'avez évoqué une entreprise
piano à brutalement licencié 800
personnes par visio cet été c'est
inacceptable c'est révoltant et depuis
le mois de juillet nous entretenons des
relations bien évidemment avec le
gouvernement anglais mais aussi avec
toutes les partenaires de l'Union
européenne pour faire face à cette
situation et trouver des solutions et
donc sous l'autorité de la première
ministre et aussi du président de la
République nous faisons de la lutte
contre dumping social une priorité de ce
gouvernement et donc cet été j'ai
rencontré notamment Jean-Marc renvoyer
de l'entreprise britanniférisme mais
aussi tfe-cgc la CFDT la CGT au fond on
a fait la semaine dernière une réunion
armateur de France inédite entre les
organisations syndicales patronales et
le gouvernement pour avancer très
concrètement sur le sujet avec trois
orientations un d'abord nous allons et
je vous l'annonce renforcer les
contrôles dans le transport pour et bien
démontrer notre exigence pour la
protection sociale de nos marins
deuxièmement j'ai mandaté en août une
mission de l'inspection des affaires
maritimes pour mettre sur la table
toutes les options d'ici Noël notamment
la loi de police qui interdirait l'accès
depuis un port le départ ou l'arrivée
d'un port français à tous les navires
qui ne respecteraient pas des mesures
sociales élevées et puis vous l'avez
indiqué c'est un enjeu aussi pas
simplement pour le transmence mais pour
la Méditerranée et au fond aussi pour
toutes les activités maritimes et donc
très concrètement dans le projet de loi
de d'accélération des énergies marines
renouvelables nous avons étendu là aussi
un dispositif pour renforcer et des
mesures sociales renforcer le modèle
social pour les questions liées aux
énergies marines renouvelables vous le
voyez le gouvernement a pris conscience
de ses enjeux et je salue tous les
députés les sénateurs qui se battent sur
ce sujet aussi et j'aurais très
prochainement une discussion avec mon
homologue anglais quand il sera
définitivement installé pour à la fois
renforcer les contrôles et avoir et bien
une politique bilatérale qui nous permet
de lutter contre ces pratiques déloyales
et inacceptables je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le ministre de ces
orientations effectivement elles sont
importantes parce qu'aujourd'hui l'enjeu
n'est pas de mettre plus d'argent sur
les entreprises mais bien de faire en
sorte que les conditions de concurrence
soient respectées et c'est bien je
l'apprécie ce que vous avez proposé à
l'instant donc il apporte effectivement
que l'on puisse à la fois convaincre les
autorités britanniques pour ce qui
concerne de tranchement et espagnol ne
pense qu'il concerne la Méditerranée
notamment à ce que nous soyons exigeants
aussi exigeants pour ceux qui viennent
dans nos ports que nous exigeons des
entreprises de notre pays il envoie bien
sûr de l'avenir notamment de la
britanniférisme qui est le premier
amateur employant des marins en France
et nous souhaitons que le modèle
maritime français plus plus persévérer
il est important que demain la France
qui est un grand Paris maritime quand je
le disais tout à l'heure puisse
continuer à l'être et nous comptons sur
vous monsieur le ministre pour cela
merci la parole est au président
Jean-François Rapin pour le groupe les
républicains
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues la guerre
entre la France et l'Allemagne redevient
possible ces mots interpellent ils ne
sont pas de moi mais de Jacques Attali
qui quitterait ainsi sa tribune dans Les
Echos au lendemain même de la rencontre
à Paris entre messieurs schols et Macron
pourtant qualifié de constructive elle
ne l'était en tout cas pas assez pour
déboucher ne serait-ce que sur une
déclaration commune à la presse
qu'est-il sorti de cette rencontre des
groupes de travail pas de quoi nous
rassurer monsieur le ministre la guerre
en Ukraine signifie un changement
d'époque mais l'Allemagne continue de
jouer cavalier seul elle sort du chapeau
200 milliards pour amortir la crise
énergétique refuse notre demande de
plafonnement européen du prix du gaz
choisissent SpaceX pour lancer ses
satellites achètent des équipements
militaires américains sans égard pour
nos projets communs de char et d'avions
de combat lance un Bouclier antimicile
européen sans la France seront seuls
après demain à Pékin à qui elle vend le
port d'Hambourg monsieur le ministre
vous nous devez la vérité la confiance
est-elle en perle avec l'Allemagne
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre délégué
sciences du commerce extérieur vous avez
eu la parole monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
Président rappin le couple
franco-allemand a été à la Fondation
même des Communautés européennes et il
est depuis lors un moteur essentiel
l'entretien entre le Président de la
République et le chancelier Scholl c'est
à Paris mercredi dernier a permis de
réaffirmer une ambition commune et de
définir une méthode de travail pour les
prochaines semaines la France et
l'Allemagne sont convenus de rechercher
dans tous les domaines dans tous les
domaines des perspectives communes face
au défi de notre temps plusieurs
chantiers plusieurs chantiers ont été
lancés la mise en place d'un fond
franco-allemand pour l'innovation la
rénovation des structures du partenariat
franco-allemand ou encore la
constitution d'un réseau entre les
futurs élites de nos deux pays nous
allons approfondir le dialogue
franco-allemand en particulier sur
l'énergie la défense
peu spécial ou encore l'impact de la
politique économique américaine sur
l'Europe notamment l'inflation réduction
actes et je peux vous dire que nous
travaillons nous avons travaillé tout le
weekend extrêmement bien lors du Conseil
commerce à Prague avec nos amis
allemands
cette nouvelle approche nécessitera un
travail important du gouvernement qui se
matérialisera d'où l'espéron dès le
Conseil des ministres franco-allemand
prévu autour du 60e anniversaire du
Traité de l'Elysée en janvier prochain
pour sa part la ministre de l'Europe et
des Affaires étrangères madame Colonna
travaillera étroitement avec Madame
Anella berbock qu'elle rencontra dans le
cadre du G7 en Allemagne à Munster puis
Laurent sauvera plus longuement à Paris
fin novembre nous souhaitons définir les
axes de travail pour agir en
franco-allemand sur les sujets suivants
l'Ukraine et en particulier sa
reconstruction à court et à long terme
le renforcement de l'autonomie
stratégique de lieu ou encore l'Afrique
notamment notre présence au salaire vous
le voyez le couple franco-allemand
demeure solide il travaille en confiance
et il est bien décidé à agir ensemble
pour relever les défis de notre temps je
vous remercie
monsieur le Président rappeur
monsieur le ministre vous avez parlé de
couple j'ai parlé simplement de relation
la construction européenne s'est faite
après guerre grâce à la convergence
d'intérêts entre une Allemagne qui
cherchait la rédemption et une France
qui voulait incarner sa puissance les
temps ont changé l'Allemagne ne s'excuse
plus elle s'affirme et la France est à
sa remorque déjà distancié en matière
économique notre pays risque à présent
le déclassement diplomatique tout ceci
parce que l'élargissement de l'Union
européenne va recentrer géopolitiquement
l'Allemagne au centre de l'Europe
est-elle capable l'Allemagne aujourd'hui
de mieux articuler ses intérêts propres
avec l'intérêt stratégique supérieur que
nos deux pays partagent une Europe de la
paix et de la liberté
la parole est à notre collègue Sébastien
plat pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicains monsieur le
Président Madame la Ministre et mes
chers collègues la souveraineté
énergétique française est mise à mal la
piste des énergies des carbonées
produites localement et la
diversification des approvisionnements
apparaît comme une solution d'avenir
l'hydrogène est une piste sérieuse qui
présente de nombreux atouts notamment
celui de décarboner les activités
industrielles et les mobilités le plan
d'action ripower eu insiste sur la
nécessité de créer un réseau de
distribution à l'échelle européenne
cette dorsale concerne 21 pays et
viserait à interconnecter les centres de
production régionaux et nationaux pour
se prémunir de la dépendance au gaz
russe il permettra d'alimenter les
usagés industriels parmi lesquels le
premier homme d’hydrogène vert et
d'éolien offshore à Port-la-Nouvelle
maillon essentiel de la transition
énergétique en Méditerranée occidentale
portée par la région Occitanie et
financée fortement par l'Europe l'État
et la BPI c'est dans ce contexte avec la
plus grande surprise que nous souvent
appris dans la presse la naissance d'un
nouveau projet de gazoduc sous-marin
entre Barcelone et Fos-sur-Mer baptisé
Barma barbares peut ignorer et balayer
d'un revers de main la stratégie de
développement en Occitanie d'une filière
industrielle de massification de
production et d'énergie d'hydrogène des
carbonée déjà en face opérationnelle si
le projet Barma va dans le bon sens nous
n'avons aucune information ni sur son
impact économique ni écologique ni sur
la stratégie énergétique visée
contrairement aux projets initial meat 4
qui reliait les centres de production
régionaux ainsi que les utilisateurs
industriels de Bordeaux à Marseille
madame la ministre pouvez-vous nous
assurer que lors du prochain sommet
européen d'Alicante les 8 et 9 décembre
la région Occitanie aura confirmation
qu'elle sera bien connectée au projet
barbare via le point industriel de
Port-la-Nouvelle
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
ministre de la transition énergétique
d'un panier runes
Président Mesdames et Messieurs
les plats d'abord je veux vous dire
l'engagement de la France pour soutenir
une filière hydrogène bas carbone vous
le savez c'est un des grands axes de
notre politique industrielle et de notre
politique énergétique puisque nous
investissons 9 milliards d'euros dans
cette politique au travers notamment du
plan France 2030 9 milliards pour faire
émerger toutes les briques
technologiques de la filière hydrogène
bas carbone électrolyseur pile à
combustible solution de stockage et
notamment pour porter un projet à
Port-la-Nouvelle de production
d'hydrogène décarbonée pour la filière
transport et également
un projet qui va permettre de décarboner
nos industries et d'accompagner les
collectivités locales qui en feront un
levier de décarbonation je pense au
projet de l'agglomération de Dijon par
exemple pour les transports en commun ou
au train hydrogène vert que porte
plusieurs régions dont la vôtre celle
d'Occitanie pour revenir à la question
que vous ce que nous avons ce que le
président de la République a décidé avec
ses homologues portugais et espagnol
c'est deux décisions fortes la première
décision c'est de renforcer les
interconnexions entre la péninsule idée
ibérique et la France en matière
d'électricité car c'est le premier
levier pour faciliter la production
d'hydrogène sur base bas carbone et
c'est ce que nous allons en faire la
deuxième décision c'est effectivement de
constater la difficulté à mener à son
terme le projet midkal et de le
remplacer par une solution
sous-marine qui relierait Barcelone à
Marseille pour en faire une
infrastructure hydrogène c'est
infrastructure elle viendra en support
des autres infrastructures hydrogènes
que nous allons devoir développer pour
porter nos ambitions hydrogène mais je
veux vous rassurer ici l'Occitanie a
pris des engagements en matière
d'hydrogène vert qui sont forts et nous
allons continuer à l'accompagner parce
que ce sont des solutions créatrices
d'emploi parce que nous avons besoin sur
notre territoire et parce que nous
souhaitons faire de la France indé
leaders mondiaux de l'hydrogène monsieur
Sébastien plat
madame la ministre ce n'est pas les
moyens effectivement 8 milliards d'euros
vous l'avez dit sur les moyens colossaux
pour l'industrie hydrogène des carbonées
c'est la méthode qui interroge pour
poids bon et simplement raison que le
projet Barma sort du chapeau et vous
l'avez dit c'est une décision du
Président de la République directement
avec ses homologues espagnols et
portugais sans aucune concertation
localement avec les acteurs qui
portaient meat 4 dans les acteurs
industriels et les élus il y a encore au
moins la DGC qui était pas au courant de
ce projet là donc il y a réellement un
problème de méthode cela dit merci
beaucoup à l'ancien Premier ministre qui
a mis énormément d'argent sur le projet
de Port-la-Nouvelle donc c'était un
projet industriel pour le pays le
problème c'est que si on interconnecte
pas pour la nouvelle au projet barbare
ça fonctionnera pas l'Occitanie et
l'Aquitaine passera à côté pour que le
futur des énergies de l'hydrogène
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
Philippe Tabarro pour le groupe les
républicains
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
car oui il y a urgence à décarboner nos
transports pour cause de santé publique
mais pour faire accepter une réforme qui
va impacter d'ici à deux ans près de 40%
du parc automobile et donc des Français
il faut informer écouter accompagner ce
qui n'avait pas été fait jusqu'à enfin
la semaine dernière devant les 43
présidents d'agglomérations concernés
vous avez repris quelques propositions
du Sénat rejetées à l'époque par la
ministre Pompili comme le prêt à taux
zéro la révision du schéma de
restriction et l'infectivité des
contrôles mais le préalable à tout ça
demeure un développement massif de
l'offre de transport en commun de la
France périphérique vers nos
agglomérations pour réduire cette
fracture qui mine notre pays monsieur le
ministre à défaut de freinage d'urgence
ou de rétropédalage n'est-il pas temps
avec pragmatisme de revoir l'ensemble du
dispositif des zones à faible émission
pour vous répondre la parole est
communiste de la transition écologique
et de la cohésion des territoires
monsieur
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Philippe Tabarro
d'abord je vais mettre beaucoup de
joie et de précision à vous répondre sur
la deuxième partie de la question j'ai
trouvé que l'introduction était d'autant
plus abrupte que il méritait pour
travailler avec eux Clément Bones je
peux vous assurer que il est pas dans
l'esbroufe et ce à quoi nous travaillons
dans le cadre de la planification
écologique c'est précisément à vous
présenter des investissements massifs
avec je le dis une méthode c'est d'abord
d'avoir le rapport du coi c'est oui
auquel vous appartenez qui a pris soin
d'auditionner tous les territoires pour
qu'on ait une remontée des besoins qui
permettent ensuite de déterminer la
feuille de route et pas de mettre
l'argent avant de commencer par se
mettre d'accord sur les sujets c'était
l'esprit de l'homme 1 ça doit être la
méthode pour la pour le pour le 2 pour
la saison 2
en ce qui concerne les aides
vous avez raison sur le fait qu'il y a
deux impératifs
extraordinairement important le premier
personne ne le conteste
en tout cas je veux dire ici
nous ne pouvons pas continuer à regarder
les morts de la pollution atmosphérique
sans réagir et même si santé publique
France l'ensemble des éléments dont nous
disposons permettent de mesurer qu'il y
a une amélioration de la qualité de
l'air 47.000 morts en 2021 liés aux
particules fines ou dioxyde d'azote ça
nécessite de donner aux élus de
proximité les moyens pour agir
mais à côté si on mène une politique
écologique si on mène une politique pour
lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique qui se fait contre les plus
fragiles on perdra leur adhésion et on
transformera une cause juste en une
nouvelle levée de boucliers des uns
contre les autres et on fera de
l'écologie un combat ou une guerre au
lieu d'en faire un chemin et quelque
chose de désirable c'est exactement
notre ambition un comité ministériel
tous les six mois pour les retours
d'expérience l'ouverture d'un travail
spécifique sur l'accessibilité sociale
la réflexion mesure d'accompagnement les
premiers moyens dans le cadre du fond
vert la réflexion sur des dispositifs un
peu sur le modèle de Strasbourg qui
permettrait à des voitures même qui ne
sont pas dans les bons critères
d'accéder un certain nombre de fois dans
le centre-ville une intensification des
primes avec l'abandon de la réciprocité
sur la surprise ZFE une campagne de
communication nationale l'année
prochaine autant de sujets ou sans
détricoter l'ambition on pourra
effectivement faire en sorte de
travailler ensemble à améliorer le
dispositif
monsieur le ministre n'oubliez pas
également de redonner la main aux élus
locaux sinon vous êtes des feux vont se
transformer en zone à forte exclusion
merci merci
[Musique]
la parole est à notre collègue Stéphane
rue dulier pour le groupe les
républicains vous avez la parole
merci merci monsieur le président
madame la mise de la culture le monde de
la culture est en mémoire est en
effervescence après la nomination par le
Président Macron de Pierre-Olivier Costa
à la tête du musée marseillais le Mucem
en effet plusieurs haut fonctionnaires
spécialiste de l'art et de la culture
ont dénoncé cette nomination qui selon
eux du pur copinage monsieur
Pierre-Olivier costard ancien directeur
de cabinet de Madame Brigitte Macron
ancien chef de cabinet du président de
la République
ne répondrait pas aux qualifications
nécessaires pour ce poste alors madame
la ministre ma question est simple
qu'elles ont été les critères de
sélection retenues pour asseoir la
nomination de Pierre-Olivier Costa à ce
poste
pour vous répondre la parole est aux
porte-parole du gouvernement Monsieur
Olivier Véran monsieur le Président et
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur de régulier excusez
l'absence de madame la ministre de la
Culture elle est actuellement au cours
de l'assiste à la commémoration en
hommage de de Monsieur soulage
m'interroger sur la nomination de
Pierre-Olivier Costa la tête du Musée
des civilisations de l'Europe et de la
Méditerranée le fameux et le fabuleux
Mucem marseillais d'abord sur les
procédures de nomination il n'y a pas eu
d'appel à candidature ce qui n'est pas
une exception monsieur le sénateur ils
ne sont en effet pas systématique du
tout pour ce type de poste et pour une
bonne raison
beaucoup de candidats souhaitent garder
la confidentialité sur leur candidature
car il se trouve être eux-mêmes au
moment où une candidate pour un poste à
la tête de lieux de prestige en matière
culturelle
c'était le cas par exemple pour le musée
du Louvre c'était le cas également pour
le Théâtre National de Strasbourg en
revanche la ministre de la Culture
confirme qu'elle a reçu plusieurs
candidats qui avaient manifesté leur
intérêt pour le Mucem sur le profil
maintenant de Monsieur Pierre Olivier
Costa sa légitimité pour ce poste est
reconnue parce qu'il a exerçait une
grande partie sa carrière dans le
secteur culturel il a participé au
lancement du Journal des Arts il a eu
diverses responsabilités au sein de la
Réunion des musées nationaux il a
travaillé au sang au Centre Pompidou au
Centre national du cinéma avant de
rejoindre la ville de Paris et la
présidence de la République Monsieur
Pierre-Olivier Costa a 54 ans ne limitez
pas vos commentaires au 5 dernières
années de sa carrière professionnelle
alors qu'il a dédié la quasi-totalité de
sa vie professionnelle au monde de la
culture son parcours montre sa
connaissance fine des enjeux et du
fonctionnement interne des institutions
culturelles des collectivités et de
l'État et il a donc toutes les qualités
pour porter une vision stratégique et
insuffler une nouvelle dynamique au
Mucem le projet qu'il porte pour le
Mucem est apparu comme le plus solide et
le plus innovant
renforcer l'ancrage territorial du musée
ces relations avec les acteurs de la
région sa politique éducative mais aussi
ouvrir de nouveaux champs d'action avec
le monde de la santé ou sur les enjeux
de la biodiversité
sur le rôle du lieu
merci Monsieur ministre mais je crains
fort que vous n'ayez pas compris le sens
profond de ma question
car clairement il s'agissait de nous
dire où s'arrête la compétence et où
commence la récompense car au-delà du
choix et vous l'avez souligné de la
personne vos méthodes interpellent
aucune publication de vacances de poste
aucune publication d'appels à
candidature à la suite de la décision de
départ de du prédécesseur de Monsieur
Costa je voudrais simplement vous faire
un parallèle avec Monsieur Castaner qui
est pressenti pour diriger le Grand Port
autonome de Marseille
rappelez-vous de l'Ancien Monde
rappelez-vous Jean-Christophe Mitterrand
qui en 1986 a été nommé par son père aux
Affaires africaines parce qu'il aimait
les voyages j'ose espérer que Monsieur
Castanet n'est pas pressenti parce qu'il
aime les effluves du vieux ou encore
mieux les merguez l'odeur des merguez
syndicales qui s'est propagée dès
l'annonce de la nomination de Monsieur
Castaner le président Macron le
président Macron avait promis un nouveau
monde alors si vous plaît songeant
arrangé ces vieilles recettes
[Applaudissements]
nous en avons terminé avec les questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
et prochaineur au lieu mercredi 9
novembre à 15h la séance va être
suspendue elle sera reprise à 16h30 pour
l'examen du projet de programmation des
finances publiques pour les années 2023
2027 la séance est suspendue